[Musique]
l'égalité des chances pour tous
nous sommes une équipe
[Musique]
nous sommes c'est diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
et
la gauche aujourd'hui et surtout faible
parce qu'elle a déçu parce qu'elle n'a
pas répondu aux attentes et aux espoirs
qui étaient placés en elle pour vous
c'est quoi finalement
l'enjeu principal les législatives où la
présidentielle nous souhaitons parler
avant tout à toutes celles et ceux qui
n'y croient plus qu'ils s'abstiennent
aujourd'hui voyez il ya énormément de
français aujourd'hui qu'ils ne veulent
plus aller voter puisque vous parlez de
son nouveau souffle à gauche
cela s'inscrit dans un rassemblement on
a du mal à comprendre l'idée d'une
candidature communiste je ne souhaite
pas que dès maintenant on nous dise et
bien vous n'avez pas le droit de
présenter votre candidature de quel
droit aujourd'hui on pourrait dire ça
laissez les français décider oui le
parti communiste français soit de
pouvoir incarner l'alternative le
changement l'espoir
[Musique]
le parti du controversé premier ministre
arrive en tête en bulgarie selon des
sondages de sortie des urnes
conservateur boïko borisov brigue un
quatrième mandat
les élections législatives qui se
déroulent après une série de scandales
l'été dernier qui a fait descendre dans
la rue des milliers de bulgares
[Musique]
le corps d'un virus flambant d'indre les
contaminations couteau au plus haut
depuis six mois ce samedi plus de 89 me
le nouveau 4 que vides ont été recensés
en 24 heures bombay sa région seront
confiées à partir de demain
[Musique]
ce vague d'arrestations en jordanie
l'ex prince héritier 2000 frère du roi
est soupçonné d'avoir comploté contre le
royaume il a été interpellé comme une
quinzaine d'autres personnes dont
plusieurs ayant occupé des postes à
responsabilité
le prince indien est désormais assigné à
résidence
[Musique]
et
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france il est crédité
d'environ 25% des voix le parti du
premier ministre bulgare en tête des
élections législatives de ce dimanche
selon plusieurs sondages de sortie des
urnes
le vote protestataire a toutefois
récolté est davantage de suffrages
qu'attendu boyko borisov appelé à la
démission
l'été dernier accusé de liens avec
l'oligarchie
il brigue un quatrième mandat retour sur
son parcours en images
d'abord garde du corps puis chef de la
police nationale
boyko borisov est propulsée sur le
devant de la scène politique en 2005
lorsqu'il est élu maire de la capitale
bulgare sofia
dans la foulée ils font son propre parti
le gr b uf acronyme de citoyens pour le
développement européen de la bulgarie
en 2009 il devient premier ministre
borisov cultive depuis une image d'homme
du peuple en langage simple et direct
rapidement l'ancien policier se tourner
vers bruxelles ils déclarent souhaiter
défendre les valeurs de l'union
européenne et s'assure ainsi de bonnes
relations avec les leaders du continent
un discours prévu qui lui permet
d'obtenir le déblocage de fonds
européens
pourtant sa carrière politique connaît
quelques remous en 2013 le pays est
secoué par des manifestations contre la
hausse du prix de l'électricité
vivement réprimées par les forces de
l'ordre borisov démissionne et pointe du
doigt les violences policières
une stratégie payante ce qui lui permet
de remporter les élections législatives
anticipées de 2013 et 2014
à l'été 2000 20 boiko borisov est
affaibli par un scandale de corruption
des milliers de personnes se réunissent
chaque nuit dans les rues pour réclamer
sa démission
en réponse le premier ministre cesse
toute conférence de presse et ne seront
plus au parlement
sa campagne politique il choisit de la
monnaie sur les réseaux sociaux
une stratégie qui semble porter ses
fruits puisque son parti conservateur le
gr b est donné favori dans les sondages
borisov pourrait devenir à 61 ans le
chef de gouvernement en poste le plus
longtemps en europe après le départ dans
gala merkel et les bulgares contaminée
par le kobe dont pu aussi je voter pour
ces législatives
grâce à une urne mobiles portés par des
agents électoraux
une initiative bien reçu par la
population pour que des personnes plus
jeunes au gouvernement pour voir du
changement et surtout je souhaite une
bonne santé
je souhaite que davantage de personnes
se rendent aux urnes que chacun fasse
son propre choix et que ce soit pour une
meilleure bulgarie
[Musique]
je suis très heureuse d'avoir eu cette
chance de voter car il est important que
chacun puisse faire usage de ce droit
que nous avons aussi été infectées par
le virus en novembre dernier j'ai réussi
à m'en remettre et je considère
maintenant qu'il est de mon devoir
personnel est de mon devoir publique
d'aider les autres avec ce que je peux
j'ai décidé que je pouvais aider pour
les élections et c'est pourquoi j'ai
accepté de faire partie de ce groupe de
votre mobile
et pas sûr pour autant que cette
initiative d'urnes mobiles fassent
grimper le taux de participation au
scrutin l'abstention pourrait être très
forte rappelle alexis trout chercheur en
géographie et géopolitique spécialiste
des balkans
en fait il faut voir que depuis l'élu la
transition politique entre systèmes kony
est un système libéral en bulgarie comme
dans beaucoup de pays des balkans
d'ailleurs il ya une tension
relativement forte
d'autant plus que boïko borisov est
quand même entâché d'une réputation de
corruption ce qui amènera les gens à
vraiment sortir le moins possible
et puis dernier point contrairement au
voisin
faire beau macedonia qui ont mieux géré
la crise du coc vide
c'est vrai que maintenant monte en
bulgarie nous et on part maintenant en
inde après cinq mois de décrue le nombre
de contaminations est reparti à la
hausse ces dernières semaines plus de 80
9000 nouveaux 4 qu'ovide ont été
recensés en 24 heures état le plus riche
le mar à ce crash dont bombay est la
capitale sera donc confiné à partir de
demain
il avait tant à escosse décontamination
de masse et la peur de voir une
situation devenir incontrôlable avec
près de 90 mille nouveaux cas recensés
par le ministère de la santé ces
dernières 24 heures l'inde se prépare au
pire
ce bilan journalier constituent un
record depuis le 20 septembre
l'état le plus touché est le maharashtra
où se trouve bombay la capitale
économique du pays
les autorités réfléchissent à la mise en
place de nouvelles restrictions
c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui je préviens
d'un confinement total
je ne l'appliquent pas tout de suite
mais dans les deux prochains jours si
les choses ne s'améliorent pas aussi
dans un ou deux jours je ne trouve pas
d'autre option
alors je ne vais pas accepter la
situation telle qu'elle est actuellement
un confinement qui pourrait paraître
inévitable au vu de l'accélération de
l'épidémie
les indiens s'inquiètent et se montre
prudent le coc vide infecte même les
grands de la société et le grand public
doit maintenant prendre des précautions
supplémentaires
c'est la deuxième vague le coc vide
s'était arrêtée mais maintenant il se
répand encore plus vite
donc nous devons le prendre très au
sérieux et faire très attention
oui j'ai l'impression que les cas de co
vide se répandent très vite mais cela
dépend de l'immunité de chacun nous
devons être prudents maintenir toutes
les mesures de sécurité prises par le
gouvernement indien et tour viendra
certainement à la normale quelques
villes indiennes ont déjà pris leurs
dispositions ferment les salles de sport
et en limitant les fréquentations dans
les bars et les restaurants
pour faire face à la situation le pays
accélère depuis jeudi sa campagne de
vaccination en l'étendant aux 45 60 ans
65 millions d'indiens ont déjà été
vaccinées en priorité les personnes
âgées et les groupes vulnérables
l'objectif du gouvernement est
d'atteindre 300 millions de personnes
d'ici fin juillet sur 1,3 milliard
d'habitants
avec 12 millions de contaminations
recensés depuis le début de la pandémie
l'inde est le troisième pays du globe le
plus touché derrière les états unis et
le brésil
le taux de mortalité de 118 décès pour 1
million de personnes un taux assez
faible comparé aux autres pays mais qui
pourraient s'envoler et géographe et
directeur de l'institut français de
pondichéry fredrik l'on dit revient sur
la campagne de vaccination en écouter
les campagnes de vaccination je pense un
en inde comme ailleurs sont peut-être
pas la solution mais une solution très
très forte
ces campagnes de vaccination ne sont pas
mener comme comme les autres campagnes
de vaccination je pensais la polio je
pense à beaucoup de maladies extrêmement
dangereuse en inde qui sont centrés sur
les besoins des gens sur les
disponibilités d'accès des populations
pour pour la vaccination contre le
contrôle commune c'est tout à fait autre
chose il faut se préinscrire ceux des
sites internet qui ne marche pas
forcément et qui a un smartphone en inde
1 seulement un tiers de la population
donc c'est ainsi d'un système qui marche
pour une élite et sans doute dit on l'a
aussi qu'il ya peut-être des enjeux
électoraux
parce qu'on veut on veut s'approprier et
la passion de ces de ses élites urbaines
notamment la première journée de
confinement étendu à toute la france une
tolérance est accordée jusqu'à demain
pour les déplacements mais dès mardi ils
seront limités pour tout le monde à 10
kilomètres autour de son domicile un
nouveau confinement de quatre semaines
pour endiguer la troisième vague de
l'épidémie
l'exécutif me
de plus que jamais sur l'accélération de
la vaccination
plus de neuf millions deux cent mille
français ont déjà reçu une dose la
vaccination qui sera ouverte aux
enseignants et personnels éducatifs
probablement vers la mi avril annonce le
ministre de l'éducation seront
prioritaires ceux qui travaillent avec
les enfants en situation de handicap
vacciner mais avec quel sérum les
volontaires se pose visiblement la
question ainsi à calais ce samedi 5 150
doses du vaccin d'astrazeneca n'ont pas
trouvé preneur sur les 750 proposé en
cause à la mauvaise publicité dont
souffre le laboratoire suède au
britannique depuis plusieurs semaines
les 572 de fighters green tech compte
elle en revanche été vite écoulée avait
plus de 5300 malades ducobu 19 en
réanimation selon les derniers chiffres
la pression hospitalière continue
s'accentuer pour faire face à l'afflux
de patients emmanuel macron a annoncé
mercredi des renforts supplémentaires
dont ses services
selon le chef de l'état il sera possible
de passer dans les prochains jours à
plus de dix mille lits contre 7665
actuellement chef du service de
réanimation justement à l'hôpital
lariboisière à paris
bruno megaman déplore une gestion
purement comptable des hôpitaux
voici une vingtaine d'années que l'on
réduit le nombre de lignes notamment en
réanimation mais aussi dans toutes les
autres spécialités ont réduit le
personnel soignant car comme vous le
savez la gestion de l'hôpital public
s'est fait uniquement sur des critères
qu'on tape on en est arrivé à un système
qui ne travaillent que en flux tendu
c'est à dire en fait qu'il ne peut faire
face à aucun afflux plus important de
patients par rapport au rythme habituel
même en termes de l'offre de soins
seules les activités médicales ou
chirurgicales dites rentables
économiquement parlant sont sont choisis
à l'inversé certaines activités peut
être coûteuse difficile et bien sont
négligés le nombre de personnes qui
travaillent à l'hôpital et qui ne voit
jamais de patients qui sont uniquement
dans les bureaux a augmenté de façon
exponentielle depuis ces dernières
années
et donc ceci à l'évidence désormais lui
à la qualité des soins et une troisième
vague de kobe 19 qui touche toute
l'europe chaque état membre de l'ue y va
de ses propres restrictions sanitaires
pour freiner l'épidémie
si l'italie et l'espagne avaient
initialement opté pour un
assouplissement attirant ainsi les
touristes elles ont drastiquement changé
de ton vis-à-vis des voyageurs le récit
de quentin mauclair avec des contrôles
aux frontières renforcer l'espagne durci
le ton face aux français voulant
franchir la frontière par voie terrestre
depuis mardi ils doivent désormais
présenter un test pcr négatif de -2 72
heures en cas d'oubli les conducteurs
n'ont plus qu'à faire demi tour et je
pense que c'est le seul moyen de laisser
passer des gens c'est plutôt pas mal et
c'est de demander le test vous allez
combien de temps là en effet la journée
c'est pas trop contraignant de de faire
un test pour sortir la journée
la joie non pas le show si l'espagne
commencent à montrer les dents c'est
parce que les fêtes clandestines se
multiplient sur tout le territoire à
madrid
353 réunions illégales ont été recensés
le week-end dernier un nombre important
qui crée la polémique
en cette semaine de pâques les espagnols
sont soumis à de strictes restrictions
les déplacements inter régionaux sont
interdits tout comme les rassemblements
un plus de quatre personnes en intérieur
en parallèle les touristes allemands
arrivent en nombre dans les îles pour
profiter du soleil on est déprimé sinon
on ne peut pas continuer comme ça et ils
ne peuvent pas continuer comme ça ils
doivent permettre aux gens de voyager en
était maintenant ils ont déjà dit que
nous devions rester à la maison pendant
toute l'année fait tape suivent nous ne
sommes pas autorisés à voyager à
l'intérieur de notre propre pays parce
que le taux d'incidence est plus élevé
qu'ici parce qu'ici c'est 30% nulle et
en allemagne y en a plus de 100 pour
cent mille habitants
c'est pourquoi nous sommes autorisés à
voyager ici mais c'est totalement
injuste
très prisé l'italie doit elle aussi
s'adapter à la troisième vague de kobe
de 19 en février des lieux touristiques
comme le colisée de rome où le duo mots
de milan ont rouvert au public ouvrant
ainsi la porte au touriste et génial
tout hennebert le temps est superbe les
gens sont sympas tout c'est comme au bon
vieux temps avant que tout ce problème
de virus ne commence
c'est bien sûr c'est génial d'être ici
quand il n'y a pas tant de monde donc je
pense que compte tenu de toutes les
circonstances
c'est probablement le meilleur moment
que nous aurions pu choisir un répit de
courte durée désormais les voyageurs en
provenance de pays de l'union européenne
devront subir une mise à l'isolément de
cinq jours à leur arrivée sur le
territoire une mesure venant compléter
le confinement réinstaurer le 15 mars
est en vigueur jusqu'à la fin du mois
à défaut de pouvoir se déplacer à
l'intérieur de leur pays
les italiens étaient nombreux à partir à
l'étranger en ce week-end de pâques ce
qui se passe en italie et honteux un
droit constitutionnel la liberté de
circulation et violet c'est une attaque
contre la constitution ce sont les
institutions italiennes qui la comète
c'est une dictature sociale et sanitaire
je trouve absurde que l'on puisse
voyager en europe mais pas en italie
avec toutes les précautions à les avons
prises
les tests que nous avons effectuées et
les autorisations que l'on nous a
demandé
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'étrange
l'italie n'est pas le seul pays à
prendre des mesures strictes pour
espérer sauver la saison estivale la
grèce a d'ores et déjà annoncé qu'elle
ouvrirait ses frontières européennes le
14 mai prochain
aucune quarantaine ni vaccin ne seront
demandés seul un test pcr négatif
servira de laissez passer des
restrictions sanitaires qui provoque la
colère d'une partie de la population les
manifestations se multiplient partout en
europe
port du masque fermeture des commerces
éventuelle à passeport vaccinale les
protestataires dénoncent une atteinte
aux libertés individuelles
[Musique]
une
je suis ici pour la liberté
nous voulons simplement la liberté je
pense que tout le monde devrait se
joindre à nous aujourd'hui pour la
liberté du peuple
nous ne voulons pas obéir aux règles qui
nous ont été imposées ils nous imposent
comment penser comment nous comporter
il impose des mesures qui sont
dévastatrices pour notre peuple
nous ne voulons pas tolérer cela plus
longtemps nous devons leur donner un
délai jusqu'au auquel ils doivent abolir
toutes ces mesures nous voulons que la
vie revienne à la normale à ce qu'elle
était avant tout cela
[Musique]
et
nouveauté
nous ne protestons pas contre le virus
ou contre les preuves médicales
nous protestons contre la restriction de
la liberté
cela ne signifie pas que l'abandon des
restrictions et déterminera les gens à
renoncer à leurs mesures de protection
personnelle mais les restrictions et les
mesures de protection ne doivent plus
être obligatoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un mot de cette première livraison du
vaccin rro spoutnik vais en libye vous
allez le voir sur ces images à des
cartons contenant 100 mille doses ont
été réceptionnés dans la capitale
tripoli la libye où l'on constate une
augmentation des cas de kovy 19 une
hausse d'autant plus inquiétante que les
conflits sur place fragilise le système
de santé du pays
vague d'arrestations jordanie ce une
quinzaine de personnes ont été
interpellées officiellement pour raisons
de sécurité
parmi elles le demi frère du roi qui nie
toute tentative de complot et s'attaque
aux autorités les pays du golfe ont
apporté de leur côté leur soutien au
palais royal françois délai lambert ce
dimanche ammann n'a en apparence rien
perdu de la tranquillité qui le
caractérise les habitants se préparent à
dix jours du début du mois de ramadan
difficile donc de deviner que le pouvoir
royal vient pourtant de subir une
secousse politique à laquelle il n'est
pas habitué
samedi une quinzaine de personnalités
proches du pouvoir ont été arrêtés dont
le prince hamza demi-frère du roi
abdallah ii lors d'une conférence de
presse le vice premier ministre
jordanien les a accusés d'avoir porté
atteinte à la stabilité et à la sécurité
du royaume
les premiers éléments de l'enquète
montre que des personnes de l'entourage
du prince hamzeh transmettent des
allégations et des courriers à des
parties étrangères y compris à la soi
disant opposition en exil afin qu'elle
les utilise pour inciter à agir contre
la sécurité intérieure et à déformer les
faits âgé de 41 ans hamza et le dernier
fils du roi hussein fruit d'un quatrième
mariage avec la reine nord-américaine de
naissance il avait été nommé prince
héritier lorsque abdallah ii a accédé au
trône jordanien en 1999
mais en 2004 ce dernier lui a retiré son
titre pour l'attribuer à son fils aîné
dans une vidéo filmées avec son
téléphone portable
le demi frère du roi indique avoir été
assigné
danse et nie toute tentative de
déstabilisation du pouvoir comme je les
dis aux chefs de cabinet quand il est
venu me voir je ne suis pas la personne
responsable de l'échec de la gouvernance
de la corruption et de la compétence qui
se sont répandus dans notre structure du
gouvernement durant les quinze à vingt
dernières années qui n'ont fait
qu'empirer depuis je ne suis pas
responsable du manque de confiance de la
population dans leurs institutions
ce sont eux les responsables cette série
d'arrestations survient alors que le
royaume de jordanie doit célébrer son
centième anniversaire le 11 avril
prochain pour le pouvoir royal
issu de la dynastie hachémite l'enjeu
est de taille alors que le pays apparaît
comme l'un des plus stables du
moyen-orient officiellement en paix avec
israël depuis 1994
la jordanie est aussi un pilier de la
sécurité régionale pour les américains
et leurs alliés
le pays accueille également un million
trois cent mille réfugiés syriens et
près de 2 millions de réfugiés
palestiniens selon l'onu la stabilité de
la jordanie est également une priorité
pour les monarchies du golfe l'arabie
saoudite les émirats arabes unis et le
qatar ont ainsi apporté leur soutien au
roi abdallah 2 une nouvelle
manifestation pacifique en birmanie à
rangoon en ce dimanche de pâques cette
armée 2 que des centaines de personnes
ont défilé inscrit dessus démocratie
joue encore révolution de printemps
certains brandissaient des portraits de
l'ex dirigeante en scène sushi est sur
le terrain sécuritaire la situation
reste tendue des factions rebelles ont
décidé de réexaminer l'accord de
cessez-le-feu signé jan
année avec l'armée elle dénonce la
répression sanglante des militaires
contre les civils depuis le coup d'état
du 1er février les milieux gâche les
manifestations continuent malgré la
répression sanglante exercée par l'armée
elle ne tolère pas la contestation du
coup d'état qui a porté les militaires
au pouvoir il ya deux mois samedi
dernier la journée a été
particulièrement meurtrière plus d'une
centaine de personnes dont des enfants
ont été tués par les forces armées
les quinze pays membres du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies ont tenu une
réunion d'urgence ce mercredi la
situation est très préoccupante
ce n'est pas seulement aux dieux en
termes de meurtres y compris d'enfants
que j'ai mentionnés mais aussi en terme
de détention arbitraire d'eau violations
de droits de l'homme et de pression
frontières de violences accrues
toutes ces choses je pense pouvoir dire
que le conseil a été unie dans ses
condamnations de ce qui se passe le
conseil de sécurité a envisagé une série
de mesures après cette réunion à huis
clos
mais pour la chine il faut privilégier
le dialogue des sanctions contre les
militaires birmans ne ferait qu'aggraver
la situation
la violence et les effusions de sang ne
serve les intérêts de personne
nous appelons à revenir à une transition
démocratique dans ce pays
de son côté moscou se dit préoccupé par
l'augmentation des pertes civiles dans
le pays depuis le putsch des ong
dénombre plus de 500 civils tués par les
forces de sécurité des violences qui
font désormais craindre une guerre
civile
la cruauté des militaires est trop grave
et de nombreuses organisations armées et
nick manifestent clairement leur
opposition renforçant le risque de
guerre civile à un niveau sans précédent
un bain de sang est imminent la
répression menée par les forces armée
birmane a déclenché la colère de groupes
rebelles
ils demandent plus d'autonomie au
gouvernement depuis l'indépendance du
pays
parmi ces factions l'armée de libération
nationale karen qui appelle les
minorités ethniques birmanes à s'unir
contre la férocité des militaires des
affrontements entre cette faction et
l'armée birmane ont entraîné la fuite de
milliers de civils vers la thaïlande
un embrasement qui ne semble pas près de
s'éteindre 10 des principaux groupes
rebelles ont annoncé qu'ils
réexamineraient le cessez le feu conclu
en 2015 avec l'armée birmane
géopolitologue et spécialiste de l'asie
pierre picard évoque la possibilité
d'autres manifestations sanglantes
en attendant que l'opposition se
fédèrent écoutez son analyse
la plupart des commentaires des
développeurs cherchent et on part à
finir et d'autre part recherche faire
comme c'était le cas en 2000 cav cessez
le feu qui fois je dirais fiable mais
comme les choses ne tiennent pas et
comme il ya une opposition majeure à
travers le pays au regard de la junte
militaire et au regard de l'armée
eh bien il est fort probable que l'on
ait d'autres émeutes plus meurtrière en
tout cas tant que l'opposition ne sera
pas entièrement réunies nous pour le
mans on pourrait dire que c'est un statu
quo très instable mais qui peut éclater
à tout moment aux dépens ou dépend bien
évidemment comme dans toute guerre
civile aux dépens des populations
locales ont des plus démunis et les plus
pauvres et notre rubrique art est sûre
l'om sélection d'articles à retrouver
sur notre site arte france point tv à le
procureur de paris annonce l'ouverture
d'une enquête après la diffusion d'un
reportage de la chaîne m6 il révèle à
l'existence de dîners clandestins
luxueux auquel certains ministres
auraient participé
l'enquète du parquet paris aura pour
objectif de vérifier si des soirées ont
été organisées en méconnaissant
règles sanitaires et de déterminer aussi
quels ont été les éventuels
organisateurs et participants au royaume
uni chez une cérémonie du vendredi sans
interrompu à londres par deux policiers
en raison du non respect des mesures
sanitaires certains paroissiens nous
portons pas de masquer le diocèse compte
demander des explications à la police
le journal le monde avait accusé une
chaîne de télévision chinoise d'avoir
inventé l'existence d'une journaliste
française qui existe réellement le
figaro à la retrouver elle s'est dit
effaré
malgré cette révélation le monde et de
nombreux médias français qui avait
relayé l'information nous me retirer
leur infirmation nous présenter leurs
excuses pour cette erreur les articles
que vous pouvez donc retrouver sur notre
site arte france point tv et c'est la
fin de cette édition prochain j'étais
dans une trentaine de minutes à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
ce sont les trafics de drogue d'une
certaine façon qui sont peut-être les
meilleurs adeptes de la mondialisation
c'est à dire que ils ont inventé les
routes de la drogue bien avant que les
entreprises ne découvrent les bienfaits
de la mondialisation on ne visualise pas
à quel point ça peut être compliqué de
se retrouver avec dans son garage
montagnes de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose l'argent
sale devient très rapidement et très
facilement en gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dire nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
le
bienvenue à novossibirsk up nous sommes
au bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry allons faire
connaissance vous avez choisi le jour à
ba est là on est
alors je suis arrivé en 2005 pour
étudier dernière fois celle en france
étaient en 2011 et non demande pas un
petit peu non ah oui et c'est tous les
fromages tous les soucis sont toutes les
les croissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylée
les français ne le savent pas je ne
pensais jamais de ma vie faire la plonge
et autonomie vous pouvez me souhaiter
bon courage
à très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]